let's go next
to eli from texas eli you're on the air
hello david cameron yes i can
okay yeah i was wondering why
we haven't seen any news on like uh
immigration lately like uh
because i believe
uh by interest expand that obvious
administration just expanded uh trump
error policies
what what what trump era policies did
biden expand i have no um
i forgot what it was i think it was the
state state at in mexico policy where
it's like uh i think these the
immigrants seeking uh
refuge or um that may be i mean listen i
can't speak to that because i i've just
gotten back from a break and i it's i
just have not been following it recently
i think you're pointing to something
really important
the reason we haven't heard much from
republicans about the disastrous job joe
biden is doing on the border
is because republicans have been busy
criticizing joe biden for other things
including the pandemic vaccine mandates
cancel culture and the like
and as you and i probably would agree
uh republicans started criticizing joe
biden on the border
immediately when he became president
even when he had not changed anything at
that point relative to what donald trump
was doing and we knew all along that it
was just a bad faith effort to hurt joe
biden's approval rating which it did it
worked i mean congratulations to them it
worked but now they've moved on to a
different shiny object and i do expect
that if the pandemic abates they're
going to go right back to immigration
um because
i mean i don't i don't feel like like i
don't have confidence in either party
uh but i'm just wondering like do you
really think
uh the blind ministry is just gonna do
anything about it i don't think the
biden administration is gonna do
anything dramatic on immigration no and
so that's that's a reason to criticize
them but it's also a reason to
understand that the right-wing
criticisms that say that he's going
completely 180 degrees different than
trump are just lies
yeah i mean yeah that's true yeah
all right my friend thank you so much
for the call important i mean yeah the
the republicans got tired of immigration
they moved on to other things and that's
where we are
that that's where we are right now they
may get back to it you know the when
there's an election coming up
fox news stories about migrant caravans
become uh very very popular we've seen
that before